- Hello everyone.
So, welcome to another
episode of Unlocking Lily.
So, it's always been my
dream to be a speaker,
which lead me to quit my day job
to pursue this full time.
And all of you are coming
along for this journey with me.
(loud explosion effect)
So, in every episode I
take a different challenge
to really help me grow as a speaker.
So, in this video I'm going to be filming
at Yonge-Dundas Square,
the busiest intersection in Toronto.
Because I learned from Brené Brown
that if there's something
meaningful that I want to do,
I need to have the courage to show up.
If I want to be a successful speaker,
I need to be able to
deliver my speech whenever,
wherever, in front of whoever.
So wish me luck
and hope everything goes well (laughs).
All right, so today's the
day I'm going to be filming
at Yonge-Dundas Square.
To be honest with you, I
think leading up to it,
I felt so nervous even like
a month ago when I thought
about this idea.
People staring at me is going to be such
an anxiety-provoking experience,
but I actually feel really good.
I feel more excited than anything else.
I don't know.
I don't know what it is.
Maybe it's just thinking
about it over and over again,
or it could be I have been
practicing more and more
in the last month.
I don't know, but you know,
I'm right here at my house.
Things could be very
different when I get there,
so we'll see how it goes.
So we locked up our house.
My lovely husband is going to.
Look at your hair!
(man laughs)
- Wow.
- Oh my goodness!
- Looks like (mutters).
- That is like, man bun
to the max!
(man laughs)
Anyway (laughs).
He's going to drive me to the Go Station.
I'm going to take the Go Train
to downtown Toronto.
Oh, look at that hair!
- Yeah, she thinks she's all tough, eh,
but wait 'til I drop her
off at the Go Station.
She's going to start.
- What?
- She's going to start
quaking in her booties.
- Oh yeah, okay.
We'll see, we'll see.
(upbeat music)
I didn't realize I actually
missed the last train.
I came to the station a little too late.
It's either the trains run
really early in the morning,
like around 5:00 AM or
really late in the afternoon,
so I'm going to be taking the bus.
I hope I'm standing in the right spot.
I had some lovely gentlemen over there
in the Blue Jay shirt that pointed me
in the right direction.
Yeah.
So I have a new friend
here that helped me out
- Hi.
- In pointing me
in the right direction.
What's your name?
- Hi there.
I'm Greg and I'm from Beri and heading out
to the Blue Jay Games.
- Yes.
- And Lily tells me
that today, she's going
to try to face her fears.
That's what this episode's about
and it's about facing fears
and she's going ride the
route filming in public.
This is going to be your big thing.
- Yes, yes.
- So that's pretty cool.
That's exciting.
- Do you have a fear?
- I don't.
- Oh!
- I don't have any
fears that I know about.
- Fearless.
- Nothing, yeah.
I'm not fearless, I'm sure.
You know, there's always the
fear of not being successful
or not taking care of your family.
Those are always the common ones,
but other than that, no.
Nothing really.
- Awesome.
- It's just one
of those things.
- All right,
you just push to rid the fear.
- (laughs) I do, yeah.
- Right?
- Yeah, you just learn to cope
and you learn to death with it, yeah.
- All right, well, thank you so much.
- No problem.
- Thank you.
- I got to another station
and I'm supposed to take
another bus from here.
It was interesting.
I got to meet a gentleman named Greg
and after he did the
video, we started talking
and he said that he's
into leadership stuff too
and how he guides his employees
to become better leaders.
I never used to approach strangers.
It's something that I had another fear of,
but you know, sometimes
approaching strangers,
you never know.
You could learn a lot from them.
Yeah, so.
Something good came out of it.
All right guys, so I'm
finally here, downtown.
It took a long time.
I was on the bus for about
two-and-a-half hours.
I'm actually really hungry.
I'm going to go find something to eat
and then take another subway
after Yonge-Dundas Square,
so I'm actually, for those
of you who don't know
downtown Toronto, I'm really south
and Yonge-Dundas is about
20 minutes from here,
but I'm going to go grab some food
and go to the bathroom too.
Actually, that's too much (laughs),
but I got to go.
(upbeat music)
Well, I found a washroom
and I got my food,
so I'm going to try to find
somewhere that I can
sit and eat before I do
my big filming at Yonge-Dundas Square.
Yeah.
So I finally got to Yonge-Dundas Square
and I realize that I messed up.
I forgot my,
I forgot my big tripod.
I don't know, I left
it in my husband's car.
So I have my little one that Nina gave me,
so I'm going to try to use that.
Also another thing is,
I got here and there's like,
I mean, there are people here,
but it's nowhere close to as busy
as I was expecting,
so I don't know.
I don't know.
I'm thinking maybe I should
find a busier place downtown
to film because really,
I think there's about,
I don't even know, maybe 50 people around.
I was expecting hundreds,
maybe even 1,000,
but not a lot of people.
I don't know what's going on.
It's a Friday afternoon at Yonge-Dundas
and there's no one around.
Interesting.
Anyway, I'll try to figure it out
and yeah.
I'll start filming soon.
Oh, I just found out that
they're doing a Chevrolet
auto show here, so they're blocking out
Yonge-Dundas Square.
That's why no one's around.
So I also can't film there, either.
I'm going to walk down the street
and Probably go to Queen Street West,
which is another really busy
part of downtown Toronto,
so I'm going to try doing that
and yeah, you know, life happens.
You got to adjust.
You got to adjust
to when things don't
go exactly as planned.
So we'll see, we'll see, we'll see.
Everything, every
opportunity is an opportunity
to learn, guys.
All the time.
(acoustic guitar music)
All right, I found a busier place.
I'm actually at the Toronto Civic Center,
I believe it's called.
This is where we hold all our events
and there's different
exhibits going on right now.
Lots of people around.
Not as much as I would like.
I don't know what I was expecting.
I think when I wanted to do this event,
I pictured thousands of people around me,
but I don't know.
Maybe this is how busy it always is.
I all made it up in my head,
that it's supposed to be like, busier.
Anyway, so, it looks like
they're going to have a concert soon,
so kind of give you a glimpse
of how it looks like here.
There's a food truck there.
Oh, look!
There's our beautiful Toronto,
Toronto sign right there.
Okay, so I'm going to try
to find a little place
to set up my tripod
because I lost my big one.
And yeah, it's going to happen.
Testing, testing, testing.
Since I'm here at (laughs).
My first attempt in shooting,
I realized that I'm a
little bit too far away
from the action of Civic Center.
And primarily because I
couldn't find anything
to put my tripod on, so I
have to use my creativity
to go right in the
middle of all the action.
Yeah, yeah.
That's the point of all of this.
The point of all of this
is for me to face my fear
of being around a lot of people
and I was kind of far away from people,
so it's a good check in for myself.
Yeah, let me go find some place.
So I found a busier place to set up,
but the only thing is, there was no place
for me to set up my tripod (laughs).
So I have the tripod on
a bench and I'm sitting
on the floor, which kind of
adds to the awkwardness of this,
which is great because
that's what I'm looking for
and I think people are
probably wondering why
I'm sitting on the floor
and recording, but hey,
that's part of the challenge.
(upbeat music)
Hey everyone, so as I'm
here, downtown Toronto,
facing my fear in filming in public,
I thought I'd share some tips
in how to overcome your fear,
or at least push through it.
The number one thing to always think about
is how is your fear holding you back?
So for example, I want to be a speaker
and I'm going to be in
situations where I'm speaking
in front of many people
that I have never met.
I have no idea if they
care about me, like me,
or if they hate everything I have to say,
so I have to overcome that.
I'm not always going to have the comfort
of my own backyard, filming
where everything is safe
and it's my home and nobody else
is looking at me, or have the comfort
in going to the TDS studio
where it's only Evan
and our camera person, so
I needed to push through
that fear in thinking that
how it's been holding me back
all my life really helped
me go through this process
and really, kind of diminished
all the fear that I had
in filming in public.
Now that I'm here, it's
actually not that bad.
I don't feel that anxiety
anymore that I used to.
It was.
(laughs)
(mutters)
It's mostly all in my head
and when you're there,
it's actually not that bad.
The number two thing that
you want to think about
is to start small.
You don't want to go
from like, being like,
completely petrified and doing something
and then completely flooding
your system and going crazy.
So for me, I had a fear
in filming in public,
so I started off filming while
I was walking on a sidewalk.
Then I started filming in a grocery store,
and then I started filming
where my class was going on.
And little by little, it kind
of helped me build up muscle
to face my biggest fear, which
is coming here, downtown,
and filming in front of
all these people around me,
and that really, really helped.
So when you want to think about it, like,
if you have a fear of swimming,
maybe you want to try
out in your bathtub first
and then go to a shallow end of a pool
and then, later on, you could
go to a deep end of a pool.
So little by little, you're
going to train yourself
to overcome that fear.
And number three is to keep pushing!
Just because you've conquered
one fear doesn't mean
that you're going to stop there.
So for me, I've conquered this fear
in filming in public.
It doesn't really feel
like a fear anymore,
so now I need to think
about what's next for me
and keep pushing through,
and not be content
that I, mean, yes.
I'm happy that I overcame this fear,
but I need to keep going through.
So I think the next thing I want to do
is go on a big stage and speak
in front of a lot of people.
A lot.
Hundreds of people.
That's what I would like to do, yeah.
So I finished filming
my little piece (laughs)
by setting up on the bench.
It was interesting.
It was good.
I mean, I had to do what
I could with the situation
I was in.
I can't believe I left my
tripod in my husband's car,
but I had to use my creativity
to kind of maneuver.
Maneuver?
Is maneuver the right word, or is it?
Oh, manure?
Okay anyways, that's
not the point (laughs).
Maneuver around the obstacles.
But more importantly, it's beautiful here!
I used to live downtown.
I lived downtown Toronto
for about six years
before moving up north,
and I love it here.
The energy is so vibrant.
The people are so wonderful
and everyone's so diverse
and there's always something going on.
So that part, I really miss
about living in the city.
I'm going to take a walk
around and look at this exhibit
that's going on.
It's called "No Blank Brain Project,"
so I'm going to take a look
and then I'm going to head home
and go see my husband.
(upbeat music)
Okay, so I'm back at Union Station.
It's so interesting here.
There's lot of stuff going on.
Anyway, I have about half-an-hour to kill,
so I'm going to get online and answer
some of your comments because
my Unlocking Lily episode six.
No, five.
Five (laughs).
Five just came out.
Yeah, I'm excited to
see what you guys wrote.
(upbeat music)
Just got off the train.
Going to go see the husband.
Look at how beautiful it is.
Isn't that just nice?
Yeah.
What a change of scenery
from crazy downtown Toronto
to farmland.
Beauty!
Look who I found!
- Hello.
- It's my husband.
- Hello, everyone.
- Are you happy to see me?
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah.
- I'm happy to see you,
happy to see you, too.
(Lily laughs)
- So I just got back from
filming in public, guys (laughs)
and it was not nearly as bad
as I thought it would be initially.
I was like, playing up all these
scenarios leading up to it.
What if people stare at me weird?
What if I accidentally drop my phone?
What if people judge me?
What if people say things to me?
And honestly, no one cared.
Everyone was going along their merry way.
Everything was fine.
People were having a great time.
I think some people did kind of look over,
but you know, it was out of curiosity
and not like, sheer judgment.
Maybe they were judging, I don't know,
but I felt great about it.
I was so happy to be there,
downtown in the midst
of all the action.
I did have a few obstacles
that I did have to
kind of use my creativity
to kind of work around,
but it all worked out in the end
and that goes to show
that fear is sometimes
just in your head, and when
you go out there and do it,
it's not as bad as you thought originally,
which brings me to the next point.
So the question of the day
is, what is your biggest fear
that you still have yet to overcome?
Write in the comments below
and I'll join in on the discussion.
So for my next challenge,
I'm going to go to an event
and start with my why.
Because I learned from Simon Sinek,
instead of going with what
you do and how you do it,
you need to start with why.
So thank you so much for
watching and I really hope
you enjoyed my journey
throughout downtown Toronto.
It was a lot fun for me
and I actually have a special
shout-out for Halona Black.
So Halona Black wrote, "How exciting!
"It's great to have a mentor
who can push you to do
"things that you may not feel ready for.
"I need to do more of this for myself."
Yes, Halona Black, it is true.
I do have a bomb of a mentor, Evan
and he is so wonderful, and he unleashes
all sorts of belief on me
(laughs) when I need it
the most and I wouldn't be
able to do a lot of the things
I have done recently if it wasn't for him.
So, so, so thankful for the lovely Evan.
So when I first started
out on this series,
I thought it was just a
way to document my journey
and show some transparency
to you guys as well,
but I had no idea that it
would be inspiring for you
and it would inspire you to do the things
that you want to do.
And I am completely at a loss of words
of all the wonderful comments
that have been pouring in.
I can't thank you enough
and be grateful enough
and I really do hope that one day,
I'll be able to meet all of you in person.
But if I don't, it makes me
feel good that we're all in this
together and we're going
on this journey arm-in-arm.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you so much
and I will see you guys very, very soon.
(loud explosion)